this past weekend all right check check
got me there we go
[Music]
happy Monday
cellophane is
you know that so
have some fun while we ride
all right all right it's Monday
September 25th of the year 2017 and some
people want to say that it's not autumn
okay but it's autumn it's fall you know
this is winters little mixed baby you
know this is winters little mixed baby
and this thing is nibbling at our
nipples I went outside yesterday and I
could feel mother nature being naughty I
can feel her licking at the ends of my
limbs at my elbows and my lips I could I
could feel that naughty little biotch
tickling my whiskers you know what I'm
talking about and that is autumn coming
that is mother nature showing off her
fanciness you know she wanna ah she's
hanging all her clothes out to dry you
know the party's over the skinny dipping
in the you know the swim in and drinking
lemonade and the summertime activities
are over and mother nature's about to
shake them leaves off and you could even
hear birds being like and you see little
birds that could be that that one might
not even make it through the winter
you see them trying to couple up with
bigger birds bigger birds they're gonna
be able to take care of them you know
you'll see a sparrow trying to [ __ ] a
goose or you will see a you know you
will see a even a hummingbird you know
trying to UM trying to you know get in a
little bit of trying to get into some
doggie style with a with a raven you
will see things like that because some
of these smaller animals know that
winter's coming and that's all that's
going on thank you guys for joining me
man I'm excited I'm excited about this
show today we had a lot of we had look
at a sidekick on last week right a lot
of the you listeners weren't happy about
it I understand and he'll be back he's
gonna pop back in later on today
we're gonna try it in a little bit of a
new facet he's not here now so that's
gonna be good
we have we gonna get into some other
stuff oh I got to tell you what happened
to me
I got hair hair rejuvenation surgery
hair rejuvenation surgery in my head
with my own hair and what it is is they
take part of your hair out of the back
of your head and look I got enough hair
for everybody if you got a bald child
out there something you know I dude I
could dude I could uh I could put I
could make wigs for half of a st. jude's
commercial I got enough hair coming off
the back and so I'm a buddy of mine
introduced me to this dude a while back
this doctor out here and next thing you
know you know I'm in there talking to
him and he's like look you should get
the surgery you should get the procedure
and I love surgery I've always loved
surgery since I was young when I was
young I had a very small wiener
basically a wiener hole to hold the hole
in your wiener urethra or yareta it's
one of them one of them is also a singer
I don't know who it is one of them is a
I think a african-american mezzo soprano
but the urethra or the urethra my hole
basically on the on my wiener was too
small so when I would pee I was peeing I
mean I could pee it did I could pee
almost maybe 45 feet it was dumbfounding
the distance that I could urinate and so
when I urinated I would piss big on
apple juice - if I had apple juice dude
I was a basically a water gun you know I
remember my brother would carry I drink
a bunch apple juice and our brother
would carry me around and I would
basically just piss at my sister's you
know and out cuz I was just like a
weapon and but it became a strain on my
body it became like painful and so they
had to take me into the surgery area and
they had to cut you know recover Nate I
guess recover Nate my my penis hole
and so and I don't know what the exact
procedure is on that I would look it up
but I don't you know I don't want to get
into my computer I want to stay in my
brain so that's what I would do man I
got that you know I got that done when I
was young um and and then I swallowed
all them quarters had to get the
quarters out of me
I had a spine surgery a while back may
or may not have needed you know but
something about surgery and something
about procedures I think it's just the
care something when you're in there you
know when you wake up and suddenly
there's people around and they want to
know if you need anything and I think
when I was young I just wanted that care
I wanted somebody to feel you know local
you know and they come in it just seems
like you know there's a couple people in
the room you feel cared for and that's
what I liked about it and so I went in
man and people are like dude you don't
need a hair surgery you don't need any
hair transplantation you're right you're
right I don't need it but you know I
don't know if that's part of my you know
I don't feel like I have an addiction to
surgeries I don't I like them I like
Percy I like the you know the rigmarole
the signing in and then you're waiting
and then everybody's wearing the same
outfits because they're same uniforms
because of you know you're in a medical
facility everybody has on the you know
the little shoe they put these little
like shower caps on your shoes and you
everybody wears the you know same color
stuff because they're doing a procedure
and next thing you know I'm getting that
I'm getting the hair taken out of the
back of my head put it on the front of
my head so that's what happened and I'm
gonna take you through that I'm gonna
take you through that I'll just take it
do it right now we're gonna talk about
them the kneeling in the NFL a little
bit and then I'm gonna have Ari Ari
mantises gonna be back here and we are
going to have him read some of the
comments that people had to say about
him and I just want to kind of feel that
out with him you know I I did commit to
giving things a shot with him for a
little bit but I do realize that
listeners want it to be just me in them
as well so I'm not bailing on having re
n but I'm not
committing to it yet fully either so
we're just gonna feel that out and
that's life sometime you just have to
feel things out so anyhow let me take
about this hair procedure so I had a
friend that got hair and I'd never even
met this friend before this was a new
friend so this was an inaugural
inaugural friend and I said to him I
said man you got good hair and he goes
well I'll tell you this you say you see
the hair in front of my head I said yep
he goes usually you can't see that hair
unless you're standing behind me and I'm
thinking that I don't know what I'm
thinking maybe this this kid was raised
in a funhouse his daddy's a magician you
know I don't know what I'm thinking you
know maybe he thinks he's got maybe he's
on acid I don't know but he ended up
telling me that he got hair take him to
the back of his head put into the front
of his head and it just blew my mind
because it looked normal you couldn't
tell anything so anyway passed forward
two years I'm in the guys office the
other day and he's like let's let's get
it and I'm like all right let's do it so
I got the hair and you sit down you go
in there and first they run like a
little bit of a woman's vibrator along
your scalp and it looks like a little
vibrator almost for a and this I'm not
trying to be profane but like a baby if
a baby was being sensual a female baby
by themselves and was using like a
little vibrator thing this is maybe the
thing that they would use and I'm not
envisioning that while I'm saying it if
you're envisioning that I don't
recommend that but I'm just telling you
kind of what this little thing looked
like and he injects his stuff into the
front of your head and then he does a
vibrator right over it so that it kind
of like just alleviates a little bit of
the pain so they shoot you up in that
forehead dude so my head was doused up
you know I'm sober oh my fricking boy my
hairline was straight up drunk-driving
son you know I'm surprised I didn't wake
up in a you know in another hairlines
bed you feel me between the sheets with
another stranger hairline so I got that
they but they put the injections in and
then next thing you know oh they make
you take two xanaxes you taking the
xanax in the beginning annele I never
I've never been into pills I've never
been in prescription pills or anything
like that and people used to eat zan
axis and then their faces would get real
skinny and then they would have to leave
town and get better I remember that from
growing up but next thing you know I'm a
little bit woozy and they turn me over
oh no first the doctor comes with this
little tool and he starts just pushing
it into your head right and and they
start pushing it in your head and
literally you can hear your head
crunching but you can't feel it it's is
it awesome it sounds like your brain is
eating Special K or frosted flakes like
something like that it sounds like your
brain is eating cereal you know and just
the first few bites because it's crunchy
just keep hearing this crunch right this
crunch so this guy just keeps crunching
me up crunching me up crunching me up so
I'm getting straight crunched up by
another man and I've never really been
involved in anything heavily homoerotic
but um but when you've had a man and
this was a beautiful man I think maybe
from Egypt or another country when
you've had a beautiful man like that
just put 500-600 little bitty holes in
your scalp I don't I mean that must
count for beyond sex that's after so I
mean that's cuz sex is one time you know
that's one whole fill you're in you're
out you know you know you're swapping
numbers who knows you you're behind the
Shoney's who knows what's going on but
with this man with this little tool you
know he was getting full bore inside of
me so I have all the I got all these
little holes then they turn you over
they flip you over bro it's like it's
like you're an egg you know it's like
Aaron it's like you're a piece of
breakfast and this goes back to that
care and stuff that I like you know this
is what I like about all of that is that
you get cared for and that's it man they
flip you over and then they got two
shorties in there right a couple of
straight up just follicle jockeys right
these ladies show up with this little
clipper you know and they just shave a
little part into the back of your head
you cannot even like if you're standing
behind me right now you have
idea so they shave a little part in
there and then I don't know what happens
because as annexed over so I passed out
I wake up they'd ordered everybody
Chinese food no long how a note no clue
how long I'd been out but next you know
I'm jacked up lunch on sweet-and-sour
chicken I'm feeling fired up everybody's
friends you know kind of flirting with
the lady the girl that works at the
front a little bit you know I think she
was you know she had a kid but she was
you know doing her best she was trying
to go back to school I think I don't
know and next thing you know they got me
flip back over my body's digesting
Chinese food everybody has Chinese food
in their systems and and they're putting
these two the two these two hair babies
are putting the follicles in they're
replanting me no doubt they're so
suddenly I'm a sharecropper I'm
sharecropping for the from basically got
my mullet put into the front and if he
and so people can say anything about
this certain styles of hair you know and
people say Thea why do you have the
haircut you have and I say well for me
that's the underdog cut you know you
look like [ __ ] and I know that and
that's fine so let's take my looks out
of the equation
okay so let's be a little what else are
we who else are we but when I got a
little bit of that mullet now in the
front you know I'm coming something
fierce I'm coming out of the jungle if I
commit a crime they're like who did it
oh I don't know a man that had magic
growing out the [ __ ] front of his
head that's who I mean if you saw a
police car artist sketch of me it better
look like a dang just like a Thundercats
like a lion you know it better look like
something that just left out of a damn
birch and bit chillstep daddy in the
neck cuz that's how I'm living now so I
got some of the back of my hair in the
front of my hair and it makes me feel
good honestly it makes me feel even more
like a damn just like a damn pleasure
cat and and you can't even notice so
here's the thing you got these little
hairs they just put them all in these
holes right
then you don't have anything you solve
the same hair you you started out with
that day so nothing's new in that world
you got the same hair you started out
with that day so that's it so I'll keep
you guys posted you know I'm sure some
guys have had this procedure some guys
haven't had it you know I mean I
definitely worry some that I'm going to
lose my hair in the future so a lot of
that is anxiety and people can say well
that's you know it's cosmetic surgery it
is it's a cosmetic surgery you know but
yeah I guess you know I'm out here I get
nervous I get scared I don't want to you
know if I can keep my hair for another
you know if I can keep that frontline
fighting and I know I got them you know
the soldiers in the back that are legit
then I'm gonna tag-team you know I'm
this WWE out here you know out here in
these hair streets and I just tag-teamed
in the back of my head and I'm bringing
around on the front and so I still got
the same amount of back maybe - six
hundred hairs you'd never notice and now
I'm keying up the front dude so we're
coming in full throttle Double Dragon
Ball number Double Dragon that video
game people [ __ ] Double Dragon dude
whatever I don't even know so I went out
look I'll leave that not so you know I
get all bandaged up I got to still go to
my comedy right I got this hair
tourniquet on my head I can't touch the
front of my head for three days and that
part I didn't like that part brought me
down off the high clouds on my god this
isn't even cool you know it made me feel
like I wish I had never done this and in
almost a week now it was last Tuesday
that this happened I feel a little bit
like you know I guess feeling ashamed
that I did it mmm I guess I feel like
you know maybe I feel a little bit like
maybe my higher power or something had a
certain way that they want me to look in
my life
so I guess I feel a little bit I don't
know if I feel like a cheater but I feel
maybe a little bit of shame they're also
feel a little bit like you know like I
liked being in the place I liked being
in there with the people and having the
Chinese food and and getting the the
hair and feeling you know even feeling
feeling the vibrator on my scalp you
know I know that's kind of maybe
homoerotic or something
I don't know but it it was exciting for
everybody I felt like and then so then
so then I'm back out at the comedy clubs
I'm wearing this bandage here was the
[ __ ] part nobody even asked me about it
I got my head wrapped up in bandages
nobody's asking me [ __ ] nobody's asking
me how what have anything I go onstage
people thought it was a tennis band
that's when buddy tells me after how
people thought it was a tennis headband
dude it's gauze who you playing tennis
with huh
Martina not gonna live uh-huh
cuz if I see somebody with a bandage on
their head I'm gonna check in with them
I'm gonna see what's going on with them
because that's a severe thing that's
their head
you only get one head and people are out
here I got this bandage and that made me
feel honestly it started a little bit of
depression for me for the week and that
was hectic man I didn't like that
feeling nobody asked you got a buddy
wrapped up their cranium is all balled
up in cotton and swaddling cotton and
you're not even gonna check in with them
some dudes didn't even look up from
their phone buddies of mine just on them
oh yeah you know nothing so I don't know
that's all a man you know that's la for
you everybody talking [ __ ] on on all
social media about how it's the most
loving you got a loved one and this and
that and then everybody's just on their
phone screaming at the rest of the
universe about how we got to all take
care of each other but then you got a
buddy that shows up in your visual
streets out here in zone one in his own
one I say that's from 10:00 a.m. to 2:00
a.m. that's your primary zone you know
some people my buddy Danny growing up he
had that bad neck so every couple
seconds the Lord would just just
involuntarily swoop him out of Zone one
over in his own two and he's looking a
different direction but I'm talking
about zone one natural when you have
that natural forward looking where you
lookin straight
a little bit to the right a little bit
to the left that's someone and I'm
showing up in people's zone one and
nobody cares you know I guarantee I'll
walk down the street you know in middle
America out there and somebody would be
saying hey man at least they'll say
don't bleed over here you know or
somebody maybe give me a can of peaches
or do something nice but nobody nobody
asked a thing man and I and that's as
close as you can get to dying if I show
up missing a leg yeah that's that's bad
you know you got you down to one you
still got one if I show up and you know
I my hands are burned in a fire and I
can only I got a you know I have to
carry my wallet around in my hands
because I won't be able to get it out of
my pocket anymore so I'm just carrying
around my own wallet like that you know
that's that's bad but that person is
still probably gonna live but you see
somebody showed up their cranium all
balled up you know like a regifter
Christmas you know Vaz or vase and you
not even ask him what's going on yeah of
course so you know what maybe that got
me to feeling bad I don't know what that
got me to feel him but it didn't get me
to feeling very good and then the rest
of the week I've been in a little bit of
pain you know dealing with that dealing
with the head pressure but everything's
going okay and then we get to you know
I've been and I'll answer more questions
if anybody has questions about they call
in about the hair stuff you can answer
you can ask and I will answer them you
know and I'm not I don't know it's hung
about the hair stuff I started to watch
videos on the internet but then I got
away from that because I don't want to
get into the whole hair universe you
know I love I'm just like being cared
for man and you get in those facilities
and they care for you and here's the
thing if I get a certain number of
people would get the hair transplant
within the next year then mine is free
so I am I'm involved basically in a in a
pyramid scheme a haramed scheme if you
will
and and I love those dude I love pyramid
schemes you know I don't think they're
fair I don't think it's funny when
people get trapped in them I got stuck
in one as a child me and a buddy of mine
he just put $1,000 into this one and
this is back when somebody come to our
town and done a bunch of sold a bunch a
glitter mining acreage and [ __ ] you know
when they were trying to trick people
into thinking glitter mining was big and
all of that and and me and my buddy
tossed $1,000 and we each saved up all
our money and we lost $1,000 and
actually that might have been was that
in college might have been that maybe in
the first year college I don't know but
that was all the money that I had
another time I lost all my money fell
out of my pant leg I had it rolled up
and that was at a gas station in East
Texas and that was not in any sort of
pyramid scheme that was just natural
gravity and poor choices pretty much but
yeah so if I get a certain number of
people to do that hair up you know so
now I'm on that hair hunt so suddenly my
life's interesting you know I'm doing um
you know I might sprout a [ __ ]
eyebrow off a shoulder you know I might
you know my spring and eyebrow off a
deltoid you feel me so that's where I'm
at that's where I'm at right now and I'm
on that hare hunt and I'm in that hare
game what else I'm trying to go to the
Impractical Jokers tonight my buddy Sal
Vulcano if you look if you haven't seen
that show there for amazing men and they
put on a great program so I'm excited
I'm trying to get over there so we're
gonna get through this the other thing I
wanted to talk about was the kneeling
during the national anthem take a knee I
think was the hash tag right and and I
get it I get that you want to create
awareness I get it and I think do the
knee thing do it for a game I mean this
isn't the first time this has happened
let's don't you can look back go if you
go google 2016 athletes taking a knee
2015 keep going back through the years
every year somebody or a group of people
and there's been a stance and and I and
look it's a good ground this happens
every year for a few games this is the
largest we've seen it to this magnitude
you know I think the media blows it out
of proportion if some guys want to take
a knee let them take a knee you know
that's their choice you know for a few
weeks I'm not gonna really feel anything
about them I think that there's better
ways to get your point across I think
that taking a knee thing is a little
outdone you know I think it's always a
player that starts it that's kind of not
that good
Colin Kaepernick was okay he was good in
his first year in the next two years he
was not good in the NFL I'm not saying
he's not a good player but he didn't do
very well you know and so I wonder how
much of that is just him like if there's
some energy in there that it's also him
being disgruntled with that said I think
awareness that racial and discretion and
racial issues always good everybody
needs to be reminded you know I try and
remind people that poor white people
have had a [ __ ] tough time in America
and that poor people overall have a
tough time in America I'd rather see
somebody take a knee for the financial
disparity in America that continues to
grow I'd love to see that I'd love
somebody to see somebody take a knee for
how gas stations are allowed to sell
sour milk you ever gotten this [ __ ] you
go get some milk for your children and
next thing it within night you have 90
minutes dude you have 90 minutes to use
that milk that is the Jack Bauer of milk
that is 90 minute Jack Bauer sauce
that's that that's that Jack Bauer
bottle dude in 90 minutes gas station
milk is going to be sour so you better
get it any a kid's mouth get it wherever
you need to get it but I get taken then
I get taken the knee you know I get it
but I think take it against some other
stuff how about take it against laziness
you know take it against you know third
and fourth and fifth gen
raishin people in america just sucking
off the system you know I just feel like
there are it just sometimes the the
cause is just kid it gets like I've
heard it before you know I'd like to see
a new novel way over all for almost any
cause and for me I stand for I stand for
the Pledge of Allegiance for me it's not
about me at all it's about the fact that
I am blessed to live in America that's
it that's what it's about for me now for
other people might be about something
else but I stand as long as I'm you know
know that it's going on I stand I honor
it's about the fact that you know that
millions of people you know lost their
lives so that I could have this freedom
right here freedom of speech so it's
crazy too and that to me is something
that's a little crazy it's like you're
you're expressing your freedom of speech
but in a way that kind of to me seems
like you were or putting shade or
casting a downward light on the people
that sacrifice their lives for it so to
me that's kind of how it seems you know
so I just I see some taking Annie for
other stuff you know I'd like to see
taken me for racial violence in all
directions and and the racial
inequalities that everybody faces sure
do it for a game or two you know but
let's let's get let's also play football
let's make it about what it is you know
let's these guys are playing sports you
work at an office this is an office you
know and it also is weird though that at
the beginning of your office they happen
to say the Pledge of Allegiance but I
think it's just because it's an event
that gets so many people together so
many diverse groups of Americans
together that that's when they want to
do it you know maybe the NFL shouldn't
have ever it put it in but I don't know
it kind of it's it's the national
anthems the things they put in at the
beginning of everything
there's a neat video of one of the
Pittsburgh Steelers and their team chose
not to come out of the tunnel and be
involved during the national anthem at
all which I thought was interesting at
least they're saying we're gonna we
might all stand for it but we're gonna
stand for it in our locker
but they had one player who had served a
few military tours Villanueva was his
last name and he came out and there's a
cool video of him out there by himself
saluting the pledge saluting the flag
and endless and and and standing up for
the Pledge of Allegiance you know I live
here I'm happy to live here I'm happy to
be here I'll always I'll always stand
for the Pledge it's not about me it's
not about me and that's just my thoughts
man you can have totally different
thoughts and if you do call me let me
know I want to know more about them I'm
happy to have my mind opened up as well
all right we're gonna have our E Madison
studio in just a second
we're gonna read to him and have him
read some of the things that people said
about him being in last time I'm excited
I want to thank everybody who's been
supporting through patreon and that's
patreon.com slash Theo von you can
donate any amount from $2 to $10 and I
want to thank you to everybody we are
almost 250 donors so I'm really really
happy about that in a genuinely
appreciate that
I'm excited the money's going right back
into the podcast we're gonna do some
neat things okay we'll be right back
with ari Maness back in the studio
reading some of the comments that people
made about him and this isn't to shame
anyone that made them this is just to
kind of get into that space of what
that's like
all right this past weekend by now
everyone knows that Dollar Shave Club
ships amazing razors for a few bucks a
few buckaroos I've been a member for a
while that's true and I love my shave
I'm not fully Shawn right now but you
know I love it when I am which you might
not know is that Dollar Shave Club also
has products for pretty much everything
else I need in the bathroom body Walsh
shampoo hair gel lip balm everything lip
balm as soon as I heard Dollar Shave
Club had other stuff than razors I was
sold at the store there are too many
options you can't tell the difference
between any of them what is this is this
shaving cream is this a hat and if you
have any questions the clerk doesn't
know most of the clerks are only working
there because the court assigned
so if you're like me and you're sick of
the nonsense at the store now's the time
to try out Dollar Shave Club for a
limited time Dollar Shave Club is
basically giving away their starter set
to new members only five dollars this
starter set features their executive
razor and three trial sized versions of
their most popular products that help
you stay fresh and clean
dollarshaveclub.com slash weekend this
offers exclusively available
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash weekend
for five dollars off the starter set
check it out
re Mantis is back here guys re how are
you I'm good
you know I've had a week to to recover
and do my own thing and fun weekend have
um great yeah what about this man i'ma
play this for you right now all right
listen up probably a lot of the other
people that love you show is it it feels
like you're talking to us you know it
feels like it's just you and I in the
room in the car I see you constructive
criticism constructive being the key
word I love your work you're gonna have
a sidekick just make sure the sidekick
knows he's a sidekick and not a co-host
it's the old 80/20 rule right I mean 80%
CEO 20 percent sidekick people come to
your channel to see you again nothing
wrong with re okay a couple of call ends
right yeah I got those those were fine I
mean those are like they said
constructive criticism yeah it didn't
sound like they hate me nope the one guy
was just like we are here for Theo and
the next guy was like nothing again
sorry so I appreciate that
yeah I think there's some truth to that
maybe I talked a little too much I don't
know I I haven't actually gone back and
listened real isn't okay
the ones that got to me who were the
YouTube comments
okay youtubers you got any of those yeah
I have one right here um here once you
read it it's the top one on this one
from a guy ara glasswork sounds
was actually so let's see what he has to
say he said oh okay dude is a whacky
piece of [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] if your
girl buys a lamp grow the [ __ ] up douche
at ya and by Judy meant you I'm guessing
yeah I think him I think he meant me as
well yeah you know I and I think that
was one of the more popular comments on
the video to that hurt as well if some
of these video comments you know you're
always gonna get the haters right when
the number one comment is a negative
thing about myself that makes me go wow
the whole world just just doesn't like
me well do you feel like the whole world
doesn't do you feel like just it's a
whole this this whole world okay you
know so you felt like it was you felt
like it was when that dude said read it
one more time dude is a wacky piece of
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] if your girl buys
a lamp grow the [ __ ] up douche hat and
then there was a little hat symbol
yeah I think I did have a good bit of
plusses on the thing yeah and no no that
wasn't you know you know what mmm
that one was funny he said the word
douche I did I was pretty good yeah and
I remember he has an emoji on it he had
a point behind it yeah
so that and that's the other thing that
hurts a little bit too is it's not
haters it's they have a little truth
behind them I say each one you know what
I mean it's not yeah I'm saying you suck
right cuz then I feel like I do or did
you feel like a douche when you were
here
we don't know II feel I was here I was
just it was just me and you I was being
me yeah you were being you yeah and I
felt fine I wasn't trying to be funny I
didn't know Hawaii feeling like I was
this funny guy but I you know I didn't
feel obstructive and so yeah that
morning when I when it came out and I'm
reading the comments it's stung a little
bit but because I spoke with you that
evening for a few minutes on the phone I
just said I said look I called just said
man don't know don't let your feelings
get hurt you know keep your head up will
you know think about it yeah and you
know if I'm if I'm patting myself on the
back if I'm cheering myself up I got to
think you did 40 something episodes by
yourself
yeah and then I come in yeah they don't
even see me yeah it's weird not even
really tell him I got you off about it
yeah well I had a lot of fans that have
said look let's let's get somebody in
here you know let's try and you know
they want to try something new and so
that's what I'm trying yeah exactly so
it was a lot of change yeah and I don't
take it too personally and I realize you
know when you put yourself out on this
public forum like this on YouTube you
have to be ready for this kind of thing
you got to be ready for the hate to come
in sometimes this went together like a
mayonnaise and jelly sandwich you need
to look for your peanut butter so that's
and that's from Chucky Duncan I didn't
see that one and I used to actually push
buggies but the dude named Chucky
and this was down at Tom this was down
in at a winn-dixie or an a MP store
could is he that guy no this kid name
was Chucky dude and his big trick was
but some of the parking lot was kind of
downhill right so he would get at the
high end and he would get him one of the
ah he would get in like the back buggy
he'd get a big line of buggies and he'd
get in the back one right so at the back
like almost the you know the caboose
yeah and he'd light himself a cigarette
and he would just he get the whole line
going I mean pretty quickly kind of
going downhill in this parking lot and
then he just smoked the cigarette the
whole way down like a train Burton he
was like a train and then he just kind
of Coast them all into the grass he had
dreams you wanted to be a what's the
word called train but it's
anti-climactic a little bit but anyhow I
like to set up with the sidekick gives a
little bit of a different flow that was
no Lucky Strike sent that in yeah there
was a few positive ones
I got a few tweets saying we liked you
got a few messages on my Instagram so
what it wasn't all negative it was just
mostly negative
no more co-hosts no real opinions just
trying to impress Theo without trying I
didn't feel like I was trying to impress
you too much only one person knows dude
yeah me yeah yeah I wasn't know I think
there's an element where like we want to
you know you want to you know best be of
service to the podcast and I and that's
one reason why I wanted to like you know
they've had other people that I've
thought about oh maybe we need to try
them out don't I kick see how it goes
yeah and that's really what I was trying
to just be observers and and I think the
one thing I did
of service besides the technical aspects
of things is I set it up great for the
next guy yeah you know they're gonna be
like not working our it was like yeah I
think whoever's on necks is gonna is
gonna have it a lot easier yeah sure no
matter who it is but yeah look we talked
about it and we said we're gonna try
this out yeah we're trying it out we
don't know how it's gonna be yeah I
would you know I don't expect this to be
in every single week type of deal this
is your show we have to get rid of that
dude that was another one that was the
whole thing yeah see that one yeah
there's no nothing behind it see that
those are the ones that are like come on
at least give me something please give
me a chance
yeah or give me some notes can this
[ __ ] sidekick guy interrupt you
anymore and I also I put my own
intonations on that sentence but that's
what it was written by Brandon gray the
concept could work at the side peace
knows their place and doesn't get too
damn frisky with the mic I guess yeah
it's weird - I didn't when I left I
didn't think oh I was talking the whole
time I guess I I guess I talked a lot
for a sidekick I don't know but I didn't
feel like I was interrupting you and
taken over the show but I guess maybe I
did well we didn't know we didn't know
what it was gonna be you know and we
don't and we still don't know yeah I do
know that this time we decided we're
gonna have already come in we were gonna
address this we're gonna talk about some
of these talking about it yeah see how
you felt and then we're gonna have
already take over the news and that's
what we need get into right now are we
gonna throw up some topics we're gonna
get into him let's let's get into that
ari this is the first story I got
Virginia woman bitten by copperhead
snake inside a Longhorns steak house oh
man is it okay that I am a little bit
[ __ ] turned on right now
yeah she's cute actually a lot of
hotties working long horn usually did
yeah the managers a good dude he hires
hot chicks and puts them in their boots
and they come and they beat this saddle
they have this thing where when it's
somebody's birthday they with a drag my
sister your sister work into this exact
the LongHorn Steakhouse and that's all
Virginia but she used to work there so
they would drag this saddle out of the
back dude it is so bizarre it's like you
know some of those places have the
birthday song you know it's like you
know I'm happy birthday to you you know
yeah
and then that long when they drag this
old saddle out of the back right and
it's got like mayonnaise stains on and
stuff it's a straight bust right you
know like the managers been just plowing
chicks on it after work it's a real just
it's basically kind of like it's so like
handicapped kids I think can like
pretend that they can go on a horse kind
of thing you know so I don't know I
guess they get like a whole bunch of
these the company does long horn and
then they give one to each place from
like you know maybe one of those
handicapped camps or something summer
camps and went out of business so then
they get these they drag out of the back
and they sit you wanted whoever's
birthday it is and they put like
streamers and [ __ ] on you they put a
cowboy hat on you put like a lasso on
you and then they sing happy birthday to
you and that's what happens at those
kind of places so I just want to give
you some context and my sister worked
there for a while yeah and then she said
she wanted to get an acting because she
thought she was good at that because
that job made her feel good about acting
yeah like she thought just because she
put on these shows she's like well I'm
doing this was this is her she's like
I'm doing shows at work so I'm thinking
about maybe getting some headshots taken
and I'm like and that's where I realized
that my sister and I have this divide
that we'll never be able to mentally get
on the same page you know because I'm
that I'm not denouncing her but I'm just
saying you don't spend the $250 three
hours on headshots
because you're singing happy birthday to
people at alone steakhouse right
that's not show work maybe sign up for
an acting class maybe it made you
realize you enjoy that kind of thing you
take a smaller step yeah okay so what
happened they're only the headline again
do you mom or time yeah sure Virginia
woman bitten by copperhead snake inside
a long hoards a Longhorns steakhouse and
what happened was she's gone there to
eat she felt something bite her foot she
reaches down and it's a baby copperhead
snake and luckily her boyfriend used to
breed reptiles so he knew exactly what
to do he took the snake out he knew what
kind of was he he killed the snake he
called the paramedics
said my girl just got bitten by a baby
Copperhead you gotta get her they come
pick her up they take her to the
hospital they give her some anti-venom
is that hey I feel like this is hazing
cuz they're shutting fraternities down
for the same type of [ __ ] you know yeah
I mean in a way you know they're bitin
our animals are out there they have
raccoons or something bit some kids in
the nuts down there in University of
South Carolina or something a couple
years ago and they're you know I don't
know I mean I guess it's why when you
when you mix animals with humanity
it's wild anything can happen and it's
just the kind of place it says that they
have any sort of padding in there any
animals in there regularly or no that's
the thing it's just a regular LongHorn
Steakhouse there was no animals supposed
to be in there yeah they just got this I
wonder I wonder if they're liable for
any sort of thing cool little reptile
story yeah it is man I mean it
definitely it makes you a little more
excited to be a long horn Steakhouse
yeah cuz I think like the environment
and there's kind of mundane well for
sure it makes you wear closed toed shoes
yeah if you don't go into a longhorn
steakhouse after reading the story with
the sandals on [ __ ] and you look down
you should look down and watch where
you're walking do it I don't need in
sandals bro and then me that's a little
bit homoerotic that's like wearing uh
that's like wearing shorts to church
when I see a guy's knees in church dude
I'm out bro alright next next story a
cafe is giving its customers water
soakers to shoot pigeons because it's
fed up of being bus' aged i don't know
if i read that last word rye just want
to get the animals so the see the seeds
and i guess their beads
I guess animals poop and are out there
eating and there's something amazing
it's about pigeons that they have the
capacity to [ __ ] and eat and like a moat
like it's like it's almost like one way
or the other it's like there's they're
either taking some in their mouth or
they're [ __ ] there's no down time
yeah there's not a whole lot of down
time yeah though I mean I've seen videos
of people putting alka-seltzer and
feeding that to pigeons and watching the
birds explode yeah so I mean this is
pretty I'm okay with with shooting a
pigeon with the water gun to get rid of
him
yeah my father when I was growing up
they had a he's to pay this black man
named
stooop and he he stood well there's the
nickname was stupid they stood he stood
he had one of his legs a little short on
the other hmm so he would stand on this
stoop you know when a little bit of a
stoop and he was staying there all day
to make him look even so if you're just
driving by he looks even now if you know
I mean you get up there and talk to him
close he realized that he's uneven huh
but my father used to pay him to take us
to lunch my dad used to work at this
little shop and when my dad had to watch
as he'd pay this man to take us to lunch
get hot dogs and pigeons would always
attack him in the park because it was a
period in Louisiana I feel like we're
honestly I don't think pigeons
I don't know somebody's racially
training these pigeons are not but they
were attacking a lot of black people
really yeah
or black you were being mean to them you
know at night and that you weren't
seeing that part of it in the minister
and the day the pigeons were striking
back
I think whatever you have to realize
pigeons are smarter than we think that I
didn't know pigeons could do that could
be racist yeah I mean I think it's just
enough it's like that cause and effect
thing you know it's like and I think
it's you know I guess it was happening a
lot I don't know I don't know exactly
what's happening but I could see
somebody who's either trained in pigeons
to be racist or there's the only two
things I could think that would be
occurring is somebody's training them to
be racist is you can train Birds yeah
they have birds doing all kinds of stuff
think about something that birds do they
deliver messages though that's pretty
smart yeah Birds deliver messages birds
they're using bird organs in other and
transplants a bird tissue into people
they made somebody something out of part
of a bird recently it makes sense they
have great eyesight they could scout
little rodents from up in the sky that's
fast and some of their eyes are so small
think about how acute their eyes must be
they must be yeah they've great eyes so
that would make sense that they could
easily distinguish colors of people
bird's eye view how strong is a bird's
eye that's a great question depends on
the bird bird vision here it says right
here man and I'm gonna see I'll use
Wikipedia do it as my own as my source
most of the time that's right sometimes
the vision is the most important sense
for birds
since good eyesight is essential for
safe flight and this group has a number
of adaptations which give
actual superiority to that of other
vertebrate groups a pigeon has been
described as two eyes with wings so that
right there tells you
pigeons are in that you know they're
about that life and I could so anyway
but yeah these pigeons would attack this
man when he would take us to lunch a lot
of times and it got to the point where
he couldn't take us to lunch anymore
then in the French Quarter because in
the French Quarter there's a lot of
pigeons down there yeah it's not even
worth going to lunch with a guy if
you're just gonna get shat on by pigeons
the whole time at some point it's like
I'm gonna go get lunch by myself yeah
all right I think I could take care of
our news the news baby re I want you to
stay for this first caller man okay I'm
excited about this and I want you to
stay for this first caller sounds like a
plan yeah let's get to it right now
can you hear on other calls too and your
audio I think so
okay great man alright let's take this
one in here we go hey Co uh got a caller
from Albuquerque New Mexico
I'll leave my name out so uh my
girlfriend's friend a couple of months
ago I'd say Albuquerque New Mexico
that's dream catcher country Ben over
there I went to high school in Roswell
New Mexico couple hours away did you
really buy the aliens yeah I went to a
military High School over there yeah I
was a my parents didn't and I didn't get
along so they sent me away to a bad boy
school but that adds a way creepy level
to you I didn't know that she rendered
by the aliens yeah over alien country a
couple years all right let's get into
this call so this guy's calling from
from Albuquerque
I'll leave my name out so uh my
girlfriend's friend a couple of months
ago I'd say out of nowhere she's posting
pictures on her Facebook was a whole
bunch of money so my girl decides to
message her and ask her you know hey
how'd you come up on all this she got a
new car she got a new purse and the girl
tells her how'd you come up in that loot
huh it's dripping yeah then that's my
first thought yeah
he's trippin and I hate to think that
about girls but that's an okay theme to
think okay there's this dude on snapchat
giving money away he's having a little
contest if you guess how fat his friend
is on the dark
you get $10,000 oh my god that's that's
a cool contest Oh give it a shot it's
like when they used to do those you
count the jellybeans in the bin yeah
it's kind of like that
but now you got to count the eternal
jelly beans into a in a human's in a
human's physical system how fat my
friend did you get $10,000 yeah
onward Sochi Adam you know we tried a
few times we almost win a couple times
but uh I want to know what is guess one
of the pictures yes I'm gonna have to
text this guy and I'm gonna see if I can
add this in on YouTube but get a picture
of the fat friend onward dude notice is
that my girls are liquor and he got he
slides into her DMS asking if she wants
to really make some money that as she
could you know give him a night of her
time for wait for it
Leonard jeez and what about the fat
friend I guess he's out at this point I
guess yeah I wonder what his involvement
as well does he know what's going on oh
that's called the fat and switch when
you put your fat friend out there and
then you reel him in the back I'm gonna
offer up that hundred grand so now that
guy's offering a hundred grand to be
with the guy's girlfriend yeah they made
a movie about this in Haiti so onward
100k one night overtime you know at
first we laughs start researching this
dude he's having dinners with Diddy all
kinds of big names and na karoti
concluded it you know but I decided
that's the definition that's selling
your soul you know so so you know we
declined but I told her you know let's
see let's see how much you could really
get out of this guy flirting a little
bit yeah let's put let's see yeah yeah
so a couple weeks go by after we kind of
squash that had some fun with it and
then we kind of just forgot about it
about a month later he he hits her up
though that he's gonna be in Albuquerque
uh-huh
oh I just happened to be passing
throughout but yeah like that's a real
common thing I'm just rolling through
the Kirk does that ever happen I don't
think not
that I know of I know I would have never
gone there if it wasn't for military
school he had to build a military school
to even get people to come and check the
joint out Marin's from that worker is he
really a sight now that isn't actually
doesn't even surprise ya
he seems like a desolate kid from
Albuquerque all right let's see you the
end of this here he ups his uh offered a
$300,000 and you know we were kind of
solid on our stance of not taking the
money but damn Theo I just want your
opinion on this type of situation we
both got a lot of student loans yeah man
let me know love the podcast Wow and I
didn't mean to cut you off there but I
appreciate you calling yeah there was a
movie Indecent Proposal and that was a
billionaire offers a million dollars to
a young married couple for one night
with the wife so this guy I mean that's
so I guess that's happening talking
about this sounds very Saudi Arabian to
me yeah like a prince did you feel that
I'd not tell you just that it yeah but
yeah totally and that might be racism by
me well when I first heard this I was
like oh I know who's the kind of guy
that's doing this like I see it out here
a lot yeah it's like a middle-eastern
Prince yes mm-hmm
cuz I mean that's a lot of money to
300,000 they message Instagram models I
meant an Instagram model and she's like
yeah I get messages from Prince's all
the time kind of fly me out there really
mm-hmm
yeah but how I mean three hustle of its
I give him props for turning that down
that'd be hard to turn down especially
like he said he would didn't have a lot
of money he has student debt yeah yeah
he must really love that girl so I hope
they're still together and doing good
that's cool well look I appreciate you
calling in but this is is it cool it's a
I wanna say it's cool I mean it's a it's
a story it's a real thing I mean yeah I
was at the Comedy Store last night and
there's this guy I could see at the end
the guy wanted to take a photo with me
as I'm leaving right just you know it
doesn't happen to me all the time
happens to me sometimes there I just
been onstage blah blah blah so I'm doing
that and I can tell that the girl he's
with like they don't know each other
that well there's this vibe like what's
kind of the situation here you know and
then I could see it's one of these
sugar models or sure you know these
these websites where you pay a couple
hundred bucks you take the girl out for
the night sex isn't guaranteed it could
happen there might be more to it and man
there's a lot of girls out here caught
up in that business yeah it's a tough
town man it's a tough town but also like
I mean I could be out there sucking dick
you know I'm an eight mm-hmm I'm an
eight with a decent you know you know
future possible if getting better each
week I got the mullet I got the mullet
it's got to be in the front of my head
people don't realize the magic come to
look like a lion
you already do man even if the middle
falls out I'm still gonna have this
beautiful front row right here but you
know there's these are people's
daughters out here doing this
mm-hmm I don't know what it is that
causes these girls are I think mostly
broken girls broken women they're come
in LA made pursuing my leg or acting
they want the easy the easy ride yeah
they're lazy
yeah they're lazy and until that easy
jackpot hits they're kind of selling
themselves on the internet a little bit
and you know it's uh it's tough it's
tough to judge to judge them for it but
I don't you know it's hard to respect
someone fully when they do that sort of
business I worry about some women
getting confused by empowerment you know
they're like okay I'm supposed to be
empowered I'm supposed to like you know
control my body and own it so therefore
if I'm selling my own body then that's
just me being in control it's like the
same thing a guy would do yeah you know
a guy would go bang lemon for money of
course and I'm just wondering like what
the psyche is behind some of this yeah
it's uh I but I couldn't for me I
thought about that I was thinking about
that and I was like if someone offered
me a thousand bucks to have sex with her
I don't even think I could do unless she
was hot but she if she was hot she
wouldn't be offering me that kind of
money the type of person the type of
guys that are on that site are not
good-looking guys are gross guys so it's
like what would you do if you're this
kid it depends on how much you love the
girl I guess you know if it's a new
relationship a hundred 50 grand if you
could walk away with that that's saying
they split it 50/50 I don't know what
arrangement would have been when they
discussed it would she get more than 50
because she's doing most of the work
that's a good question no but let's say
it's 5050 for a hundred fifty grand I
would have to really love the girl not
to want to do that I think I'd have to
really care about her and it sounds like
he did it sounds like that was a serious
relationship so I kind of I give him
props for for being able to say no to
that kind of money yeah cuz you could do
a lot with 150 grand or 300 grand so but
yeah me personally I would take the
money yeah I don't know it's a wild call
man yeah it is that's a wild call we're
gonna get into a few of the rest of them
in just a second we're gonna say bye to
already manis see you guys thank you
very much yeah man will you come back
next week maybe and help with the news
let's see what people think yeah yeah
let's see what let's see what happens
after this week you know and I
appreciate you putting you know putting
it out there a little bit I know it's
you know you know I appreciate you
coming to kind of all know not enemy
territory but you know yeah you know for
me I appreciate coming on unfamiliar
appreciate it and yeah it's a it's a
little scary but I think I gotta
overcome your fears and keep grindin
yeah what I'm doing yeah we we should
look we're trying that's life we're
trying all right Ari was here and now
he's gone let's continue with the rest
of this past weekend onward hey JJ
calling phone you know JJ calling from
Sacramento I appreciate your call man
Sacramento where everybody looks like a
missing person if you ever spend time up
in Sacramento but everybody looks like
they're missing onward anyways really
podcast just inside my meeting at the
moment but uh I had a question man um
thanks man I appreciate that I'm coming
off of a long heroin stretch so I'm in
detox in you know just tryna with that
clean like you know I mean but I know
part of your cover
you gotta keep in mind occupied and all
that so my question to you is what are
you like favorite hobbies to do like
what was something cool that you can do
know by ourselves with some friends or
you know something like that man I mean
it's kind of trying to find something
yeah well I appreciate your calling man
and I appreciate your your aim to to
battle your addictions that's awesome
that's really awesome man it's brave
you know that's brave stuff son and you
out there and then bravery streets JJ
and I respect that more than you know
you know I just wrote I just watched a
movie the other day called Bill W and
it's the older one there's an older one
it's like a documentary if you get a
chance it's on Amazon it's only three
dollars to rent it and I bet you would
like to JJ it's about the AAA program
and just everything that how it all
started stuff it's interesting it's
inspiring to me brought a tear to my eye
a few times but let me tell you this man
things that I do I thought about this
and this may sound you know gay or not
gay or chill or whatever I don't know
dude but right now I'm kind of on a
little bit of a kick of trying to learn
why I feel like I do you know because a
lot of my life I start fine and I just I
just get get in habits my life's the
same it's Monday it's you know it's the
same thing a lot even mile even my life
even though it might seem interesting to
some people you know it's a lot of the
same stuff so I start to I started start
to try and read about why I behave the
way I do or if there's something wrong
with me
you know or there's something I'm not
doing well that I want to learn why how
can I do better and why do I feel the
way I do that's what I'm trying to
figure out I mean I've spent so long
detached from my feelings that you know
feelings for me are brand-new so right
now I'm really trying to figure out when
I feel anything like a real feeling not
just like a something short or quick or
anger or happiness so sometimes can be
real fleeting but other feelings I try
and really feel them and figure out what
they are outside of that man my hobbies
taking a walk doing yoga
getting a little surgeries bruh you know
I got that new that lion mane coming in
the front but not mating sometimes my
hobbies are just like not laying in bed
I'll wake up in the morning and and I'll
be in bed and my head will start going
and before I know what I've been in bed
five minutes just worrying or pondering
or angry and I haven't even done
anything I don't even know what my days
like so my thing is now I do not lay in
bed if I'm up and I know I'm not going
back to sleep I'm up because good things
are gonna happen when I'm happening you
know you can't think your way in a
positive actions but you can act your
way in a positive thinking so the second
I get moving good things happen but
other small things I see friends do man
reading if you get back to reading it
has a lot of peace in your life taking a
walk like taking a walk with your eyes
open not on your phone really just you
know I we're such creatures that are
supposed to move and we forget about
that especially this society today you
know we're all caught up
but yeah little things like that trying
to be there for others reaching out to
other people
I know these are weird hobbies do but
I'm on this that's what that's the kick
I'm on right now JJ so those are some of
my hobbies you know what else but yoga I
really liked the first three times you
go to yoga you're gonna [ __ ] hate it
dude you're gonna want to saw somebody
in half bro not even with a saw dude
with something that's not a saw and but
that fourth time you're gonna start
feeling that you're gonna start feeling
free a little bit in your body and your
body's going to feel in control so but
yeah small surgeries spending time with
other people what else I enjoy talking
to my brother these are weirdest hobbies
do but I'm a weird dude you know so
those are some of my hobbies I guess but
I don't do too much outside of work and
do comedy and I feel like my job as a
hobby so it's tough sometimes um when
you know when work is a hobby but that's
what I do man and I apology dude and I
love you and I appreciate you calling
him and even thinking about what else
you know other people are doing
you know because by asking other people
questions and learning from other people
when just taking
gestures or even just listening man it's
gonna help you so much in your detox and
in the next levels of jinlun with
whatever little demons you got you know
and those demons might be big man but
don't let them be big you know keep your
demons small dude you got a big life
ahead of you
all right let's move on to this next
call here we go hey I'm calling because
I don't have anybody to talk to and that
it feels pretty bad I got a question
though you know everybody they go
through things like relationship and you
know I went through one of those and I'm
out of it and I just feel really sad I
just don't know how to get back to me
and I remember being fun single me and
now all I have is a lonely me you know
he's not a good person to hang out with
I don't like very much okay so you don't
like being with yourself when you're
lonely you notice a difference on words
you know and I know everyone's gone for
that you probably have what what did you
do or what would you say to somebody who
has lost their way it has to work
Thank You Pheo I appreciate you know
evening work for me
oh man look you know I'm not I mean you
know I'm being here for you but you know
this I don't have advice you know I just
but I'm happy to share with you how I
felt man when you know when I was you
know I do when I got broken up with a
woman to be really honest with you guys
man I turned into a baby bruh when I got
broken up with in the past dude when I
wasn't in control of my feelings when I
didn't know who I was
you know when I was just you know I was
obsessed with my girlfriends but not
really in love with them I thought I was
in love with them but I couldn't even
tell the difference between love and
obsession and and just desire sexual
desire couldn't tell the difference
between some of that man one time I go
from broke up with me I put Nair in her
shampoo and she had a roommate that loss
a sideburn from it you know and that
girl was a little bit turnt at the time
so so what whatever you know and that's
that's out of legal that's been eight
years so no legalities everybody you
know good good
what else after that what else happened
after that that I when I got out of a
relationship one time do my the girl I
was seeing she took French class I
started learning French dude I spent a
whole summer learning [ __ ] French
dude I got to her to her place and uh
and that's that's the girl I met in
South Carolina and I was you know
petting a I was petting her neighbor's
cat or somebody's cat I turned into a
stalker I was over at her place in
middle of the night petting somebody's
cat and I just hitchhike to get to South
Carolina I've never been in the state
before I got there at midnight and I'm
petting a cat on the address where I
know she's been getting mail so that's
not healthy and practicing my French in
my head for how I was gonna romance her
in French dude can you imagine if she
had opened her door
here's her boyfriend that she hasn't
seen in three months who's probably been
you know senator like six and seven page
love letters suddenly this dude is on
her porch petting a cat that she may or
may not even know cuz I don't think she
owned a cat so there's gonna be somebody
else's cat that I would be holding when
she opened the door and that I'm gonna
be trying to just probably stutter in
French how much I loved her that's going
to jail that says that is going to jail
this gtj behavior right there that's
going to jail so that's how I behave so
I'll tell you this man don't be a [ __ ]
you know and I hate to say that we're
not people like hearing about don't be
it you know if that relationships over
it I mean sometimes we romanticize the
old you the fun you really was that who
you were you you know what was the wr--
you know maybe you were I'm not saying
you weren't but what just don't
romanticize things you know that
relationship didn't work out because it
wasn't supposed to work out I hate to
tell you that it might work out in the
future it's not working out now so what
are you gonna do that's the facts man
you know but if you're really struggling
with your feelings and you're not
feeling great you know pick up a hobby
you know get you a box of popsicles dog
you know go to an al-anon meeting listen
to other people share about their
feelings how they're feeling al-anon is
a great place if you don't have you not
an alcoholic or something but you've got
you lost in your feelings go there
people sharing and you'll learn a little
bit about feelings in there but I mean I
wish you weren't going through this pain
but that's what I did I later did I
learn as I smoke menthol cigarettes and
late on a swing set for a summer wasted
a whole summer of my life
another time my ex-girlfriend broke up
with me I drove across country showed up
at her place in the middle of the night
to win her back you know and I wasn't
tripping I mean I was a little bit in
hindsight but I mean I thought I really
loved her you know and I probably did I
and I did and maybe still do in some
ways but you know what did I do I
freaked out when I but you know when I
felt bad when I felt sad and I put an
arrow tell me look man I wasn't making
good choices what do I do now you know I
mean you know spending time with the
girl and we have some tough times
because of situations that I'm dealing
with and you know what do I do now I
just I don't lay in bed I don't lay in
bed and think about it man you know I
keep moving and when she pops into my
head you know get through the feelings I
breathe I meditate I get through the
feelings you know and if that's what's
going on you know but just you grown-up
stuff don't let stuff just happen to you
do stuff if you sit there and let stuff
happen your feelings gonna take over
you're gonna feel bad man you know but
if you do stuff you take action you can
feel not as bad and you probably don't
deserve to feel as bad man you sound
like a good dude you deserve somebody
that loves them you'll get that I
promise you bro you know you got big
lovers out there coming at you you know
you might have a dude hitch up on
snapchat for a couple of hundred G just
to visit that ass so you know so keep
your options open man you know but stay
up Mantle's don't stay down don't stay
down that's a Vegas [ __ ] but you know
what I'm saying man you're better than
that
you'll be okay bro love you alright be
good to yourself son [ __ ] hug
yourself and go jerk off somewhere you
know if you got a jerk off one time I'll
get addicted to it but you know sneak
out in the woods or something jerk off
connect with your manhood bring a whip
out there
how your friend to beat you with a whip
you know buddy of mine when he would get
feeling kind of squirrelly and girly
sometimes his buddy would beat him with
a [ __ ] whip in her basement
and he's a straight-up g-man so you'll
be okay bud sorry I'm in a weird mood
all right let's go to the next call mmm
soaking in the sunshine here in here in
Indiana Theo this is Bobby Indiana home
of the Ku Klux Klan just bringing that
up I just don't want that blamed on the
South anymore
onward and we've got a little issue I'm
calling from Muncie Indiana situation is
Muncie beautiful name I've always
thought for a baby for a newborn baby
Muncie look at Muncie I got a friend
named mutt seen he got someone I on word
is my neighbors I've got I've got
several several characters in the
neighborhood but there's one in
particular one couple in particular that
have an interesting thing going on so
okay what is it brother what you got I
moved into town to start my graduate
degree about about four months ago and
these [ __ ] have had a continuous yard
sale that spans their entire property
which is probably that's ballmart dude
that's people that straight-up ballmart
people that just straight up ball out in
a yard dude we had somebody like that
that's ballmart everything's for sale
always anything something gets thrown in
the yard out of a [ __ ] window that's
for sale to everything let's hear more
ugly uh half an acre or something so
they've got this uh they've got this
yard sale this perpetual yard sale going
on and I'm not really sure how to
approach it they're not violating any
policies or laws that I know of hmm
and I I have walked over a time or two
and I've actually bought a few items one
of which was a motorcycle helmet I also
picked up a fur coat and a football
jersey so damn dude I love it I love the
whole scenario what do you do there
I mean I think here's what I would do
I'd make a deal with them for 500 bucks
I buy everything in that [ __ ] yard
right and then I put it all over in a
corner and I'd burn it all but the deal
was contingent them on the fact that
they don't sell anything else ever if
not you guys got to get a neighborhood
group together like an HOA type of thing
and see if you can shut them down or
just embrace it you know embrace it next
time you got neighbors coming over take
them over to shop first thing you know
sometimes it's like things aren't that
bad if we just embrace them but
sometimes neighbors need to act a little
more neighborly my step parents live
next door to this family dude they got
11 or 12 13 [ __ ] children you know
have phones running around like damn
Frankenstein's some of them have
children they're running in and out of
the house they always have a million
cars parked in the yard they're not bad
people
you know I don't think the dad works and
I mean but they don't they're not good
neighbors that's for damn sure
you know and they had one time they had
a kid a three year old my stepdad
somebody's by the door he sees somebody
out by the front door he opens the door
they got a three-year-old out there
standing out in it like by the yard like
by right by the front door like by the
walkway and my stepdads like what's
going on it's three years old this kid
he goes I'm just wah I'm just gonna go
walk to the Dollar General and get me
something do you know which way it is to
the Dollar General my stepdad just took
him back to his house kids three years
old you know and that's a type of family
that's over there and he was making
signs and [ __ ] for a little while we'd
stay up at night just hammering on signs
like he was damn living in Santa's
workshop or something the daddy or
something I don't [ __ ] know people
are out of their minds people need to
learn how to be good neighbors oh that's
for sure you can write them a note you
can start straight up war with them if
you want you know but if but if you're
not willing to go there and you want to
live in that contention if not if you
don't if you don't if you don't want to
go there and live in that contention and
be a war with them which could be fun
too that could be fun but if not then
you need to have fun to come to some
peace with it you know
see if you know you could buy everything
one time and they never do it again
or see what you know ask him when does
yard sale end or when you have guests
over take a shopping first you notice
embrace it those are things I would
recommend it that's [ __ ] gangster you
got a fur coat out of a neighbor's yard
bro
dude we had this fur coat and these
other dogs in the neighborhood would
come by and [ __ ] it sometimes man and
then someone would double team it to do
these two honestly bro these two black
dogs I think they were Rottweilers
anyhow all when I'm taking one more call
man and then I and then I'll see what's
going on let's hear it ATL what's up my
name is Vince Paul from Tampa big V in
big t Vincent Tampa man he sound like
you sound like somebody that could have
worked at a strip club on word but then
of course everybody in Tampa does I just
had a little bit of a story for you they
saw an experience I had when I was 16
years old with my first [ __ ] ooh this
is always enticing man I loved hear
about people's first experiences so
let's go Vince bowling with my buddies
at the bowling alley
and uh I'm not some pins down turns out
I had the old 710 split that 710 split
man that's what they used to call this
dude in our neighborhood who only had he
have one tooth right there and one tooth
right there
he had that Michael Strahan he had that
710 homeward and I was born was one of
the hottest girls in high school she
comes up to me and she says a man if you
hit this 710 split I'll give you a
[ __ ] in the car afterwards really I
don't find this impossible to believe
but what kind of girl does that if you
hit this what girl even knows what a 710
split is in high school Vince I mean
think about that
some girl like if you come up and hit
this I'll give you a [ __ ] did i'ma
listen to this a little bit more but the
sound I'm uncertain about you here Vince
Oum word
they steal HDL I was born with one of
the hottest girls in high school she
comes up to me and split I'll give you a
[ __ ] in the car afterwards I'll work
bro I've never hit a 710 split in my
life and I'll be damned if my little
penis tip didn't twinkle and I hit that
710 split
i'ma hit a 710 split of my life bro
anyways man she she ended up hooking me
up in the car and that was my first
[ __ ] ever
I remember I felt like I wanted to a
little bit of shock dude it was like my
hands and my arms and everything went a
little bit and um oh that's [ __ ]
atrophy dude we had a buddy like that in
uh in junior high he got himself some
early [ __ ] and if you get early
[ __ ] a lot of times your body's not
used to it you can have adverse
reactions even to you know sexual
activity and he would uh he couldn't
even move after he after he get a
[ __ ] so literally you could tell if
he'd gotten some his buddies would be
carrying him around or they would be you
know that even have I remember one time
at after prom they had him in a
wheelchair and that's you know that
happens sometimes people can't handle
the sexual activity they're getting at
young ages and they will you know and
this dude they put him in a you know his
two buddies would care him he's kind of
a little bit of a strong in the legs you
know he had some he had some rings in
his would work if you know what I'm
saying he had some he was his legs had a
lot of atoms in them he was you know a
lot of neutrons and protons protons
anyway he was thick that's what I'm
saying he had volume he had mass he had
all of those and and so he would get
that blow job and he couldn't you know
couldn't move very well you know he get
that atrophy of his muscles and stuff
and his buddies got to carry him around
and that happens too sometimes you get
that on you take these viagra Z's see
Alice's you know I take that Canadian
viagra makes my leg sweat and I have a
buddy that used to take it he couldn't
bend his legs if he was on viagra so
he could do some sex but he had to just
lay down you know we're just leaning in
one time really good and so everybody
has different things that happened to
him with sex man but the 710 split sorry
I find it hard to believe but I love Anu
you know I love a first-time story so I
appreciate you calling in and also I
think you are a first-time caller so I
respect that we had a lot of great calls
I'm gonna get to some more of them I
don't know if I'm gonna get to them
tonight
I don't know what I'm gonna get to him
but if you have a call if you have a
response to something we've talked about
on the episode today if you have a
thought on the taken knee if you had a
thought on the taken knee man I would
love to hear more about it you can hit
the hotline and drop that call off if
you have had an experience where your
girlfriend or significant other has you
guys have agreed that they could sleep
with somebody else for money or not for
money just for recreational purposes and
how that played out
I'd love to know more about that so you
can hit the hotline for anything nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three but those are two things that I
would love specifically to know about if
you have experience with those to call
in about them if if you've had a spouse
spend time or a girlfriend or boyfriend
spend time with somebody else that you
agreed on for money or for not and how
that played out afterwards and also if
what you think on the take Annie you can
guess legit that's cool that's whatever
you think you know how many times it's
gonna happen how you know what's the
solution for what's the Reysol or the
racial solution you know I mean or
whatever whatever your thoughts are
whatever your thoughts are I'd love to
know them and I'm gonna take us out of
here thank you guys again for supporting
the podcast you can hit up the patreon
we got the Dollar Shave Club out there
everything is going okay I appreciate
the support
I want to thank re manis for being here
you can follow him on twitter and on
instagram @ re manis there's no hard
feelings between me and re as we figure
this out
I appreciate you guys calling in and
giving voicing your thoughts and your
opinions they are always welcome here
all
waise welcome here and you know we're
trying to heat them I'm trying to figure
things out you know I don't want to just
kick our by the wayside because we
agreed that we would try it for a few
weeks and see how it goes so you know
we'll figure it out after this week and
see if it's worth trying for another
week or not we try to reframe it a
little or I tried to reframe it a little
bit but thank you for checking out this
past weekend subscribe tell your friends
I love you I will be in Huntsville
Alabama November 14th through the 16th
at the stand-up live re we'll be in La
Jolla at the La Jolla comedy store and
that is the first weekend I believe in
November
it's either the first or second weekend
so you can check out when you'll be
there the third and fourth of the 10th
and 11th thank you guys so much for your
support I'll talk to you soon let's go
out
Spencer Jacob growl band with celebrate
and if you have some ideas for new music
or intro theme or something you want to
let me know you can hit me up at Theo
von at mac.com
I'm always interested in having a
variety and go out there and stand on
what you believe in man you know if
you're tired of certain things people
get tired and speak up about it you know
everybody has a voice and I we got to
use them you know if you're tired of
companies you know making shitty stuff
quit support and shitty stuff you know
when you change where your money goes
that's when things change so put your
money towards things that you care about
research the company's research who's
doing what know who you're giving your
money to because that's how things
change and poor people got to stick
together man I tell you I tell you
onward
[Music]
you guys be good to yourselves man I bet
you deserve it man I'm gonna try
you